Streaming services promised us an
affordable, convenient way to access any
song we could ever want to play.
Then they broke that contract with
restricted song libraries and higher
prices.
>> Don't want constant ads?
Then you better pay up, champ.
>> Which is just one of the reasons that
people, young and old, are hearkening
back to simpler [music] times, when
phones were phones and MP3 players had
headphone jacks.
All of which is driving unexpected
demand for classic iPods. Now, my
initial thought here was,
"What?"
But it actually kind of makes sense.
While there are many options for modern
MP3 players, both affordable and bougie,
none of them perfectly replicate that
tactile wheel interface or the sheer
old-school cool of the iPod classic.
But do you really want to load all your
music onto something with a 20-year-old
hard drive and about 13 minutes left on
its battery?
>> Yes.
>> No.
No, you don't. You're all wrong. And
that is where modded iPods come in. We
grabbed this one from Player Mods that
claims to use original parts, but with
new batteries and modern storage.
There's just
one little tiny problem. These things
are expensive, reaching as high as a
thousand plus dollars if you want all
the fixings. There's got to be a better
way. And there is. If you're willing to
get your hands a little dirty, there is
a large and supportive community that
will help you find the right parts and
perform your own modifications for a
fraction of the price. And conveniently,
our fabricator, Justin, was already
planning on building one for himself.
So, we roped him into this project to
see just how much we can save and if
it's worth the hassle.
Just like I'm going to hassle you with
this segue to our sponsor.
>> Meter. If your IT team is being forced
to work across multiple vendors, let
Meter help you with a full stack
networking structure. Check them out in
the link below.
>> Let's start with a look at our
pre-modded device. We opted for a fifth
generation iPod Classic with a 3,000 mA
battery and a 128 gig SDXC for storage.
Other than that, it mostly feels like an
iPod feels, which makes sense because
they claim to use original parts, but
I couldn't help but notice a distinct
ridge between the front face and the
rear housing, which
I don't remember that from 2000s era
iPods. Justin, you've got yours handy,
right?
>> I do.
>> Okay, let me just have a look [music]
here.
The weight is obviously different, but
that makes sense. There's no hard drive
in this one.
>> Um
>> Do these feel the same to you, though?
>> Let's take a look.
>> Here.
>> Woah, that Yeah, that lip is like real
bad.
>> Right? No, yours is Jobs would be
rolling over in his grave.
>> it's like three people would have lost
their job over that.
>> And he wasn't even dead yet. [laughter]
Other than that, the screen and
interface work like an iPod works, and
it's only if you look closely that you
start to notice little differences or or
big differences. For instance, gone is
the 30-pin connector, here is a USB-C
connector for charging and for data
transfer, which is sick.
However, it's worth noting that ours,
well, mine, doesn't support audio over
this port. So, my only output option is
3 and 1/2 mm as the good lord intended.
But, that's not such a bad thing. The
fifth generation iPod is coveted for its
Wolfson DAC chip. So, that's the
component that's responsible for taking
a digital audio signal and making it
analog so speakers and headphones can
play it. Player mod says that it is the
best sounding DAC chip used in any iPod
ever and [music] DMS confirmed that this
is a pretty popular opinion.
>> Even without mods, iPods have changed a
lot over the years. This one's a
community favorite. It's the 5.5 gen.
This one uses the Wolfson WM8758
DAC chip which, actually fun fact, all
of the iPod classics before this one
also used Wolfson DAC chips. People
claim that the chip in this iPod makes
it sound more warm and relaxed and
pleasing, but I don't think that's
actually the case. See, this thing has
what's called a capacitor-coupled
output. This changes the actual
frequency response of whatever IEMs or
earbuds you plug into it. I can't get
into all the nerdy stuff right now, but
if you want to see a full breakdown of
it, you can on lmg.gg/floatplane.
I'll put it all on this whiteboard.
Basically, the iPod classic 5.5 gen
sounds great. I daily drive this bad boy
myself and she's got a few mods.
>> And if it's good enough for him, it's
definitely good enough for me. Total
damage for this, including shipping, was
$388
and that included $30 for the taptic
engine that adds real haptic feedback
instead of just piping the click through
the speaker. It feels pretty darn good
even if the hold button
>> [music]
>> doesn't feel that good. Anyway, as long
as it sounds good, I'm good. So, let's
take it for a test drive real quick
here.
>> While he's busy, I'm going to get going
on my mods here. So, the taptic engine,
we got to go with that. But, because I
saved so much money by bringing my own
iPod, I'm going to do some extra mods
with it as well, too. So, we got an
atomic purple front face plate
here.
Got a white click wheel and center
button as well as a Bluetooth mod for it
which should be very cool.
>> I'll be going with a better USB-C mod.
This one allows you to route audio
through the USB port. So, if I want to
use wired headphones that have a type C
connector, that is an option as well,
too.
A upgraded back plate. Well, not really
upgraded, but fancy, nice and colorful.
>> Okay, that looks sick. I guess you
haven't seen this yet.
>> No.
>> Yeah, so they custom engraved us LTT
logo, Elite Obsolete Electronics, who
does a majority of these parts. One
thing Justin wasn't going to do until
Elite Obsolete Electronics just sent a
bunch of extra goodies uh was a new
screen, but honestly, looking at the
condition of your screen, that's
probably a good thing. So, we're going
to do two different price comparisons.
[music]
One where he brings his own iPod and
doesn't bother with replacing any of the
original parts, and then another that
includes the new screen. So, he'll
either be spending a little less than me
and getting more functionality, or he'll
be spending a little more than me and
also getting more [music] functionality
and also authentic parts.
All right, let's see how it goes.
Good luck, everyone.
>> [music]
>> Removing the stock 30-pin connector was
a bit of a difficult task. It was really
anchored in there. I had to use multiple
stages of heat to try and get it lifted
off, but once it was lifted off, it
wasn't too bad to anchor the new type C
port in. The pins that you have to
solder back to the original 30-pin where
it used to be, that was really difficult
as well, too. Needed a really tiny iron
to make that happen, as well as all the
tiny little bodge wires required to have
the audio pass-through.
It was quite difficult trying to find
the type C mod itself. There was a few
different suppliers that provide
different options. Some provide just a
little adapter PCB that solders on.
Others offer a full replacement back
plate with wireless charging, type C,
and Bluetooth built in. We ended up
going with the Oxo Mods type C adapter,
which at the time wasn't in stock, but
luckily, the owner of the company had
got a hold of us and was able to send a
couple boards out.
When I was assembling the front half, I
was definitely having some difficulties
getting everything together. The
tolerances seemed like they were a
little bit out in every direction. When
I initially assembled it, the click
wheel was super wobbly. It didn't line
up very well. It kind of sunk into the
front face plate and it took quite a bit
of shimming to underneath the buttons to
get it to level back out properly. It's
not really shown too well here, but I
ended up taking it apart about seven
times to try and get that click wheel to
sit flat. After I finish up the front
side, I would start working onto the
back and getting the battery installed.
I made a custom little 3D printed tray
just kind of house the battery, the
Bluetooth board, as well as the optional
little pairing button that I wanted to
install. This one is designed for a
thick case. I guess you could fit it
into a thin back as well, too, cuz the
CAD model I used was a thin back.
Um, it should work fine, but the mods
that you have inside may or may not fit
depending on what mods you're working
with.
>> Yep. That's what like a music player
sounds like.
Man.
You always miswire when you go away from
it.
And then you snag the wire on something.
You go, all right, that's why I'm using
Bluetooth. [music]
>> Uh, the tactic engine was very, very
simple mod just to install. Uh, all you
had to do was pull the headphone port
out and there's a little speaker where
you normally hear the clicking coming
from on on a stock iPod and you just
tack the two wires onto where those
little pins are for the speaker. The
micro SD card adapter was
straightforward. It's direct drop-in
replacement for the hard drive, so
nothing weird needed there. The nice
thing is with the micro SD card mods or
what compact flash, whatever you want to
swap this thing to, almost anyone can do
it as long as you have the tools to open
the device. No soldering required, just
direct drop-in replacement. It's really
nice.
>> The Bluetooth dongle that Justin's
wiring in, I imagined that this would be
a proprietary thing, but it turns out
that it's really simple and affordable
to just buy an off-the-shelf Bluetooth
dongle like this one from Ugreen,
dismantle it, and then wire it up to the
3.5 mm jack and power, and then just
stuff it into the chassis. Another
popular thing that people like putting
in these is an AirTag, but neither
Justin nor I opted for this option.
And
it's done.
Wow.
>> Not bad, eh?
>> This looks
>> [laughter]
>> freaking sick, and while it also isn't
using a genuine front or back, I got to
say the fit and finish
>> It's quite considerably better, eh?
>> [laughter]
>> So much better. Man, this turned out
freaking awesome. So, on a scale of 1 to
10, though,
how hard was it to do it yourself?
Oh, that's not good already.
>> Yeah, so we're going to put it up there
with probably about a 7 to an 8 for
difficulty, for sure.
>> Okay, so small soldering
>> Unbelievably small soldering.
>> Any removal of
>> yes. So, having to remove the original
30-pin port is a task. If you do not
have correct soldering equipment to
remove that, you are going to break
something.
>> Okay, and we're not talking just like my
AliExpress, Temu soldering iron, we're
talking like
>> like maybe not like quite this caliber,
but like a hot air station and like a
real fine-tip soldering iron with good
control is definitely necessary here.
>> Okay, but
>> but
>> with the hours invested, how are you
feeling about the end result?
>> Oh, I'm absolutely loving it. I used it
all weekend nonstop. Um, didn't even
have to charge the battery once, so the
new battery is working amazing. [music]
Uh, the Bluetooth, amazing. Total
game-changer having Bluetooth on here,
like just being able to walk around my
entire house without [music] being
connected to cords, super nice.
>> I got to be honest with you,
as much as I love my wired headphones,
and these are great wired headphones, IE
600s, It's
>> [sighs]
>> I spent most of my weekend replacing the
gate that a bear destroyed at my house.
>> Uh-oh.
>> And so, because I was working with my
hands and working with tools,
being wired up to something was just not
an option. And even though I took this
home for the weekend, I barely even
touched it.
And that's even ignoring the obstacle
of, you know, if you haven't been
maintaining your music collection over
the last, you know, 10 years of
streaming taking over, like going and
finding everything and then using iTunes
to load it onto your iPod.
>> As you I skipped that all together. Uh
there is a aftermarket software you can
install called Rockbox and it just opens
the whole thing wide open. You plug it
into USB, all your files are there, just
drag drop your music, done.
>> That does rock.
>> Yeah, way better.
>> box.
>> Plus all the other wonderful features it
has, so it can run Doom now, like all
good electronic devices. Built-in
Gameboy Color emulator, which is kind of
cool, so you just load your Gameboy ROMs
on and off you go.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh and then
>> For controls,
>> Click wheel.
It It look
>> I'm sorry to hear that.
>> ideal.
But hey, if it's the apocalypse and this
is all you got, hey, this is a great
device.
>> Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> So, having [music] done it, knowing how
many hours it takes and how much
equipment you need,
knowing that the fit and finish of these
particular ones is a little bit sub par,
which option do you lean toward?
>> [sighs]
>> See, that's a really tough one for me
because
>> For yourself,
obviously this.
>> Yeah, because A, it looks way freaking
cooler.
>> But [laughter]
if someone were to come up to you and
go, "Which one should I do?"
>> I'd buy it, unfortunately.
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah, I mean, yeah, quality's not as
good as if you could do it yourself, but
like just the hassle of not having to
put it together.
>> It works and I could totally Rockbox
this.
>> Yeah, it takes a couple seconds. Just
plug it in and hit
>> I could have bought one with Bluetooth.
>> There is a difference between how they
would have done it versus how I did it.
I think
>> Oh,
the the ones that you buy, [music]
they pair it to the menu button.
>> Right. So, you just hold it down.
>> Yeah, which can kind of get a little
messed up with your UI and things like
that. So, I did something a little bit
different inspired by another YouTuber.
I think it's Zach Builds.
He had done a custom iPod where he put a
little switch on the hold button.
>> On the hold button? Oh, that's so cool.
>> So, I followed suit.
>> Oh, that's wicked smart.
>> Yeah, way nicer, way cleaner.
>> More work.
>> So, it doesn't really change the answer,
does it?
>> No, not at all.
>> And it doesn't change this dancing
Segway
to our sponsor.
>> [laughter]
>> Meter, your IT team shouldn't be
constrained by broken systems or limited
resources. If a networking engineer is
feeling those strains, you can bet those
struggles trickle upwards. The pain
isn't just felt in monetary losses.
Every single thing a member of the team
can't focus on has a butterfly effect
across your company. And I'm not talking
about that Ashton Kutcher film nobody
saw. Meter provides full-stack
networking infrastructure that includes
internet, both wired and wireless, as
well as cellular. And what's great is
that Meter doesn't require a
rip-and-replace method. Meter designs,
deploys, and manages everything to
deliver high-performance connectivity
across any space with the goal being
predictable and relatable outcomes. They
provide migration credits as well as
24/7 support, and pricing is always
transparent. Legacy networking isn't
built for the demands IT teams face
today. Meter is. Thanks to Meter for
sponsoring this video. Go to
meter.com/ltt
to book a demo now. That's mtr.com/ltt
to book a demo.
If you guys enjoyed this video, why not
check out the one where David and I
upgraded our old retro consoles, very
similar vibe. One where you can also
just buy it instead for way more money,
but but with way less satisfaction.
>> Agreed.